dans quelques jours faire le tour de
Paris en voiture sans rencontrer un seul
feu rouge ce ne sera plus un rêve en
effet la construction du dernier tronçon
du périphérique vient de s'achever
[Musique]
Paris la grande ville était en train
d'étouffer parmi ces millions de
voitures
une cité doit pour vivre s'aérer en
échange de l'intérieur vers l'extérieur
et visser vers ça l'antique chemin de
fer s'allonge comme fugitivement à
travers les tours habités mais son débit
pour tenter normes et décuplé par celui
des routes
et aujourd'hui il ne suffit plus de
circuler vers les villes il faut les
aborder sans causer de bouchons et les
autoroutes doivent se muer en boulevard
périphérique comme celui qui a commencé
de la Porte d'Italie pour aller vers le
nord-ouest à la porte de la plaine 5 km
200 8 passages souterrains quatre ponts
deux passerelles et 2500 mètres de mur
de soutènement un milliard 200 millions
de nouveaux francs
un ingénieur nous a reçu sur le chantier
d'un de ces grands travaux qui
assainissent la circulation de Paris
de béton qui sont fantastiques il y en a
une qui est en train de se faire en ce
moment qu'est-ce que c'est oui il y a un
pont qui est en train de se faire en
face la rue Julia Bartet
et combien est-ce que ça représente 2
tonnes de béton ça fait 1700 tonnes 1700
tonnes 1700 tonnes
il vaut mieux ne pas le savoir parce que
les voitures qui vont rouler dessous
après on 1700 tonnes de béton sur la
tête mais il y a un creux formidable
c'est le parc des expositions comment
est-ce que vous allez pouvoir franchir
le parc des expositions alors on descend
vers la Seigneur une vallée et on va
passer le parc des expositions en aérien
sur un viaduc le viaduc passera au
dessus des bâtiments le parc des élèves
de la Foire de Paris le bâtiments de la
Foire de Paris on peut dire en somme que
tous ces travaux là permettront soit de
rentrer plus à l'aise et je puis dire
dans Paris soit de contourner Paris plus
facilement aussi est-ce que je peux vous
demander en conclusion de nous dire quel
sera le débit moyen des voitures admises
sur le admise sur le boulevard
périphérique sur le boulevard
périphérique qui a deux chaussées de 10
mètres 50 qui permettront un débit de 9
à 10 000 voitures heures
dans quelques jours faire le tour de
Paris en voiture sans rencontrer un seul
feu rouge ce ne sera plus un rêve en
effet la construction du dernier tronçon
du périphérique vient de s'achever si
tout va comment l'espère les
automobilistes pourront l'emprunter dès
la semaine prochaine porte Daniel porte
dauphines ce sont les trois kilomètres
qui manquaient au périphérique afin que
l'anneau de béton entoure complètement
la capitale sa construction est terminée
plus que quelques jours à attendre avant
de pouvoir l'empreinte plusieurs
ouvrages d'art ont été nécessaires le
plus important étant l'échangeur de la
Porte Maillot au pied même du futur
palais des congrès encore en
construction et que l'on aperçoit sur
cette image en haut et à gauche de ce
périphérique Paris en avait bien besoin
sa longueur totale 35 km c'est en 1960
que le premier tronçon a été inauguré à
la hauteur de l'arrivée de l'autoroute
du Sud cette portion ne comporte
d'ailleurs que trois voies les
difficultés n'ont pas manqué passage
au-dessus des voies ferrées
respecter le bois de Boulogne en passant
en dessous d'un des lacs et en
replantant aussi les arbres qui avaient
été déracinés
autre difficulté la construction du Parc
des Princes près de la Porte de
Saint-Cloud le talent des architectes
s'imposait une nouvelle fois
et il a fallu aussi faciliter la
circulation aux principales portes de
Paris grâce à deux gigantesques
échangeurs comme à la porte de Bercy une
fois engagée les automobilistes n'ont
pas intérêt à cette trompé de direction
enfin n'oublions pas les parkings que
les Parisiens et les banlieusards
boudent de moins en moins dicton
mais aujourd'hui le périphérique ne
suffit plus plusieurs heures par jour il
est bloqué des solutions il en existe
comme celle de doubler le périphérique
par un viaduc sur la portion sud autre
solution la construction d'un second
périphérique cette fois à 5 km de Paris
deux projets dont la réalisation sera
longue il rencontre de nombreuses
difficultés il aura fallu 17 ans et 2
milliards de francs pour boucler la
boucle ce matin entre la Porte Dauphine
et la Porte d'Asnières c'est un autocar
que Monsieur Messmer a parcouru ce
dernier tronçon de 3 km avant de couper
le ruban traditionnel en présence de
Madame Nicole de hauteclock président du
Conseil de Paris et de plusieurs membres
du gouvernement
le cortège c'est ensuite arrêté sous
l'un des souterrains de l'échangeur de
la Porte Maillot et c'est là que
Monsieur Messmer a tiré la leçon de
cette inauguration
on va dire que sur certaines sections
du on aurait juste plus de 160 000
passages de véhicules par jour et que
bientôt on s'attend enregistrer près de
200 000 passages sur ces sections
et
c'est passage ont allégé dans une mesure
dès maintenant sensible
les boulevards des Maréchaux où l'on
peut circuler de façon presque normale
c'est donc un succès du point de vue de
la circulation au point que dès
maintenant il est préférable pour les
véhicules qui veulent traverser Paris
sans s'y arrêter de faire la moitié du
tour de Paris plutôt que de traverser la
ville du nord au sud ou de l'Ouest à
l'Est
premier constat Paris Porte des Ternes
10 heures du matin
[Applaudissements]
chantier de construction et le toboggan
du périphérique rivalise l'intensité
que dit le premier
vous êtes habitués
même endroit une heure plus tard à la
rencontre cette fois des habitants du
canal
depuis 4 ans cette infernal ça fait 4
ans que celui-ci au mois de septembre et
ça fait trois ans que tu pouvais pas
dormir là fait ouverte infernal
j'habite juste au dessus du toboggan et
j'ai fait poser des vitres spéciales de
12 mm d'épaisseur dans les chambres
quel bruit
[Musique]